if you go to any event and we're like
let's say JJ Abrams is Trump is talking
at the event now everyone's gonna try
and zoom in on JJ but his people are
gonna be in that first row okay any any
of these bigwigs okay and if you google
who their partners are and Google Image
what those people look like you know
what those people look like sunset
trying to talk to JJ you try to talk to
his right-hand guy or James a James
Cameron you talk to his right-hand guy
because there for one thing I'll be
they'll admire the fact that you've done
your homework so you know who they are
and and all but again it's always treat
people with respect always people I
didn't want to treat it it's not about
the fast hustle it's not about oh my god
I'm going to pitch this they're gonna
love it they're gonna buy it no you're
building a career and careers made out
of relationships and it careers about
doing the work and what gains respect is
if you let's say you meet someone like
Brian Burke who's JJ's partner and you
say you know and you do research so you
know a little bit about them and you say
you know I read that your first you know
first shot you ever produced was about
you know a boy who had a wooden leg
whatever doesn't matter and you say
Brian Burke you know it's funny I you
know I looked at that short online I was
just so moving in a friend of mine is
you know my name is a kid is you know
terrible train actually lost his legs
he's become a you know decathlon athlete
and I'm doing this this little piece
about him and you know it's just then he
really inspired me so Brian Burke will
say wow that's really great the next
time you see probably but you say you
know I'm so you were so encouraging last
time you spoken I've I've actually
finished the short I love to send it to
you the fact that you said you were
going to do something in and you did it
and I'm not talking about Brian Burke
please don't everyone reach out to Brian
Burke but but the fact you did 99.9% of
people in this town or in this industry
they say they're going to do something
and they never do it which is why if you
have a screenplay and the money isn't
attached or the acts are
that's why they blow you off because
most stuff never gets anywhere and so
why should they put more effort in your
project that you're going to put in your
project but if you actually do it let's
say you make that documentary and it's
great then they start that will becoming
interested in you and they want to help
you because they see that you're serious
and everything in my career has been
about saying I'm going to do something
and then doing it I'm very strong on
that I'm very firm on that in my own
career I'm very hard on myself and very
committed but people that then
establishes the of integrity and once
people get that integrity and
authenticity are very important and once
people see you've got that they trust
you to a certain degree and then they'll
help you so it works that way you
mentioned in previous videos that you
know breaking into film and television
is really not that difficult blue as
long as you know what you're doing and
you apply yourself with dedication and
consistency yes so going back to that
same thing and keeping your commitment
not only to others but yourself what is
dedication and consistency to you even
on a daily basis exactly
discipline is very important my mom was
was raised by a single mom and one point
one of her boyfriends was a retired spy
who was also a writer and he said one of
the best things I ever heard about
writing he said in terms of writing said
an amateur can rely on inspiration a
professional needs discipline that's
absolutely true and so so minimally five
days a week off in six days a week I'm
I'm working you know and and even
unknown Space Command it's almost 24/7
now and where I'm just kind of I'm it's
my job and I and I
it but I also treat it seriously you
know I'm a writer and I have to write
and if I'm also producing and directing
I have to do those jobs and I'm not
looking for someone else to do the hard
part I'm doing the hard part you know
and beyond that I also study successful
people whom I admire and a big part of
my conversation with those people is how
they divide their day and so for
instance Ray Bradbury was a dear dear
friend and a very clear very wonderful
mentor for many many years
dearly missed you know um he I found out
his his writing schedule was five days a
week Monday through Friday he would
write for three hours in the morning
then he would have lunch and take a nap
and then do business in the afternoon
his write the business about his writing
career and then evenings or weekend's
for his family and he that he did that
for 80 years you know so you know 70 75
years and it worked really well and so
that's the best writing schedule of
anyone I know
but but but when you're a writer
producer director divides up differently
so for instance I'm not writing nearly
as much as I normally would be because
I'm running the Space Command campaign
but because I see that the job is
getting those films made it's not about
me clocking pages every day it's about
getting the films made I'm clear on what
my job is but but also you know the
moment you say if no one picked me how
would I still get to the finish line
you're free because then you don't need
anybody to say yes you just figure out
how to do it yourself
and five ten years ago that would have
been much harder in the old days if you
were shooting on 35 millimeter or 16
millimeter making a feature would cost
millions of dollars you'd be move
editing on a movie Ola print
distribution would be a nightmare
because like the studios and networks
have all that stuff locked up if you
want to reach an audience of millions
good luck if you don't have those guys
aboard now it's a totally different
ballgame if you can if you know part of
Space Command was I you know my goal
since I was 13 years old was to be a
showrunner on my own science-fiction
show I was staying in myself the other
day how can I get what's the fastest
route to doing that a help I can remove
the studios and networks I can remove
the middleman and go directly to that
and that's why I've been doing this I
Kickstarter because I don't need them
and I'm not I don't consider them the
enemy but if I don't need them if I'm if
I don't need to be wealthy if I don't
need to be making millions that
liberates me I'm free I keep my overhead
very low I've earned millions as a
writer but I'm not ruled by money and
because of that I don't need to work I
don't want to do it's free I'm free and
so in terms of getting Korean film and
TV writing a lot and getting better and
better and better and making sure your
work is solid is vital getting feedback
from people who really know what they're
talking about
is vital getting people to consider your
work to look at your work banging the
drum for yourself is vital but doing it
in a way that's it's funny I had lunch a
little while ago with Nicholas Meyer who
directed Wrath of Khan wonderful writer
director and he said the way you have a
career in this industry is charm with
persistence and he's absolutely right
or you say persistence with charm either
way the point is you're an absolute
squeaky wheel for yourself but in a
charming way so people don't think gee
what an
I could help you don't want them to be
saying that about you
I mean there's some really horrible
alpha dogs in this industry who are very
successful but if you can
you can do things with grace and
consideration one of most probably the
most the single most polite person I
know is JJ Abrams his manners are
impeccable astonishing he's so
considerate he's such a great guy and so
if he can be on top of the food chain
then it means you don't have to be a
jerk to make it in this town you know
gamma Kappa Gamma Delta maro with him
I'm doing a book he's a wonderful guy
big heart big heart it's just wonderful
and you know so that's that's how I run
my life too
you